-Our first guest tonight
is a best-selling author
and Emmy-winning host
of "All In with Chris Hayes,"
which airs weeknights at 8:00
on MSNBC.
He also hosts the podcast
"Why Is This Happening?"
Please welcome back to the show
our good friend Chris Hayes,
everybody!
[ Cheers and applause ]
♪♪
Hi! I'm so happy
to have you here.
-It's great to be here.
-It's also --
This used to happen more
with the previous guy in office,
but news breaks during the day.
And I'm very lucky to have
a newsman here with us,
because news just broke
the Trump Organization
was found guilty
on all 17 counts of tax...
[ Cheers and applause ]
Hey! Hey! Hey!!
Do you know how hard it is
to do your taxes?!
To get it right on every form?!
-They just like justice.
[ Laughter ]
It's good. Yes, all 17 counts.
I mean, I think it was
a pretty open-and-shut case.
-It did seem
pretty open-and-shut.
-They had all the documents.
It clearly --
I mean, basically
what it amounted to
was they engineered
a bunch of ways
to pay benefits and perks
to the CFO, Allen Weisselberg,
that they were not reporting
as taxes.
And, again, this is one of
those, like, you know,
"cutting corners" kind of things
that's just clearly illegal.
-Yep.
-Anyone that is, like,
working with a lawyer,
an accountant, or has,
like, a sense of integrity
is like,
"No, you don't do that."
You report your taxes.
-Yeah.
-But that does not apply
to the Trump Org, obviously.
As now has been proven --
you know, found by
a jury of his peers.
-We should stress,
this is not --
Donald Trump has not been
found guilty of anything.
This is the Trump Organization.
-No, that's right.
I was gonna make a joke
that the jury of the peers
was, like, I guess
other real-estate companies
in New York.
They were, like, sitting
in the jury box.
Yes, this was the very rare
and rarely seen criminal trial
of a corporation,
which is the Trump Org.
-Which I would imagine that,
based on the news of the day,
Trump either says
he has everything to do with
or nothing to do with it.
-Yeah, that's exactly right.
-Today might be a day
where he's like,
"I barely have heard of it."
[ Laughter ]
-It's another Trump.
-"It could be
a different Trump."
-Might be Don Jr.'s company.
-So that is interesting.
Obviously, there will be
a lot to unpack about that.
Today, of course, the reason
we're happy to have you
is it's the end of the midterms.
Tonight is the Georgia run-off.
-That's right.
-This is a fascinating race.
What is your --
Where do you see it?
Based on the outcome, what
are you going to glean from it?
-I mean, I think
there's two big --
I mean, one is,
will Georgians have, like,
an extremely competent
and impressive U.S. senator?
-Yeah.
-Or will they have
Herschel Walker?
[ Laughter ]
Like -- Like, you know --
And I don't say that as any
kind of ideological judgment.
It's just that Herschel Walker
is the nominee
to be the senator of Georgia
because he was
on "Celebrity Apprentice."
-Yes.
-And because at a certain
point, people were talking
about the Georgia election,
and Donald Trump was like,
"I know someone from Georgia.
-Yeah.
-Herschel Walker
is from Georgia."
And literally the Republican
establishment in Georgia
was like,
"No, he lives in Dallas.
He's lived in Dallas
for 20 years."
And Trump was like,
"No, that's Herschel Walker."
-Right, because Donald Trump
I think --
It' very easy
to connect the dots
that he remembered
Herschel Walker
as a Georgia football player,
excellent one,
and then knew him as a USFL guy.
-And then he was on
"Celebrity Apprentice."
-He was on
So there -- those are the --
And really not
a whole lot of dots.
-Those are
the three qualifications
for him to be the senator.
And so there's
a real question of --
It is one of -- Of all
the races I've ever covered,
one of the starkest
juxtapositions.
-Of just candidate quality.
-Candidate quality.
-Yeah.
-And then the second thing
I think really is,
after a brutal midterms
for Donald Trump's
political brand,
for candidates associated with
him and handpicked by him,
I mean, he will have managed,
if Warnock pulls this off,
to basically have cost Georgia
three Senate seats in two years.
-Yeah.
-Which I think is not
gonna be helpful for him
in the case
that he's trying to build
to run for president again.
-And it should be noted
that the governor of Georgia,
the Republican governor of
Georgia, won his race easily.
-Yes.
-This is not a state
that is swinging wildly
to become a blue state.
-No. In fact, if you look
at some of the other states,
like, for instance,
Pennsylvania and Arizona
and Michigan particularly,
like, they seemed to move more
in the Democrats' direction
down the ticket line.
Georgia kind of swung back.
The big outlier is
Raphael Warnock
against Herschel Walker.
And the reason is that
Herschel Walker
has no business
being a U.S. senator.
-Yeah.
-And enough marginal voters
in Georgia were aware of that
to give Warnock the advantage
the first time around.
We'll see if that holds tonight.
-It will be an interesting
night as we see those come in.
You talk about, is the impact
of Donald Trump
in the Republican Party waning?
It definitely seems like
things are not going as well
as they have in the past,
obviously.
But I still don't see
how he doesn't have
a massive amount of control
over the Republican Party
because of his base.
-Oh, he definitely has
a massive amount of control.
I mean, I think
two things are true.
One is that he is still the
de facto leader of the party.
Two, that he's as
politically weak as he's been
basically since he came down
the escalator in 2015.
And, you know, I think
if the last five years --
-It is funny
that that's a true thing
but also really funny.
-[ Laughs ] Yeah. Yes.
Everybody was like,
"Wait. What?"
And they were like,
"Oh, yeah. That's what he did."
-That was actually --
-That's what he did.
It's so funny, too, instead
of, like, elevating to meet us,
he was like,
"I shall come down to you."
-Yes.
[ Laughter ]
In, like, the lobby.
That was the other part of it.
-And we were like,
"Ha-ha-ha! You goon!"
And then he was president.
-Yes, exactly.
[ Laughter ]
That's exactly what happened.
-Which -- I shortened it up.
I sort of condensed it.
-But those are the main parts
of the story.
-He came down, we all laughed,
and then he was president
for four years.
[ Laughter ]
He did the full four.
-That's exactly what happened.
And because of that,
I think, like,
it's always so risky to draw
some straight line, you know,
some trend that's happening
and just draw it
out into the future.
And I think, again, the last
five years has taught us,
like, between Donald Trump
and, like, COVID,
you never know
what's going to happen.
I have no idea
what the future will bring.
He might be very strong.
Right now he is very weak.
And the reason he's weak
isn't because people
are morally appalled by the fact
that he's, like,
dining with white nationalists
and anti-Semites.
It's because he's a loser
and he keeps losing
and he keeps screwing
things up for them.
-Yes.
-And they --
[ Cheers and applause ]
They don't like that,
and they want to be rid of it,
but they're not quite sure
how to be rid of it.
-Well -- One thing I want
to say is, you know
I think a lot of candidates try
to follow the Trump playbook.
And this will seem insincere
as I say it, but I do mean it.
I do think it's harder to be
Donald Trump than it looks.
-Absolutely.
-I think that he has
a unique combination of skills
that if other people try it,
it just seems
weirdly inauthentic.
And with him, you're like,
"That's exactly who he is."
-I absolutely --
I 100% agree with that.
I think his -- The schtick
he has is his schtick.
And no one else
can really do that schtick.
Even when they try to do it,
it doesn't work, "A."
"B," it's hard to be --
[ Laughs ]
I don't want to
remote diagnose the man.
But, like, if you have,
like, a fake sociopath
and a real sociopath
going against each other,
like, the real sociopath
has a real advantage.
[ Laughter ]
And I do think that, like,
it's genuinely difficult
for most people to be
as, essentially,
sociopathic as he is.
So I think that schtick
doesn't work.
And then, I mean --
you see him with these --
Everyone else just comes off
as creeps and weirdos.
Blake Masters.
-Yes. This is in Arizona.
-In Arizona.
You know, he had this two-minute
video of him shooting --
Did you see this?
-Yes.
-Shooting the gun
with a silencer.
Just out there being like,
"Silencers get a bad rap, man."
It's like, "Whoa. Buddy."
Like...
I don't know what you're doing
or why you're running for office
on this platform.
But all of the sort of reactions
people had to Trump,
the fundamental thing
I think to remember is,
in almost, like,
the original ancient Greek
meaning of the word,
he has charisma.
-He really does.
-He does have charisma.
And charisma
is a hard thing to fake.
And not everyone has it.
And I actually think
even if you go back
and look at tape of him
in 2015, 2016,
that version of him
had a lot more charisma
than the version now.
-Yeah.
-Like, significantly more.
And that's a sui generis thing.
It's hard to bottle.
It's hard to replicate.
-Well, it'll be interesting
to watch him try to get it back.
I have a million more questions
for you. Stick around.
We'll be back with more
from Chris Hayes.